e aí galera que aceite meu canal tudo
bom vocês comigo está tudo ótimo então é
do estado de são paulo vou estar em
sorocaba bauru botucatu tem no currículo
do curso têm nota 3 só acaba 14 bauru
jack botucatu ingressos neste site aqui
é nóis é claro que falhou a ele ontem
foi assistir ontem um outro existe
atividade paranormal é um filme para
normal essa opção normal fui lá né
panamá um filme de terror e eu fui
assistir com minha namorada ou seja eu
tinha que manter tinha que manter o
padrão e na fenda não sou um homem
masculino macho hotel mas nada não reter
esse cinema com medo meu melhor e eu fui
comprar a pipoca a pipoca história na
panela
entrei no cinema começou os trailers
amor pelo amor de deus eu tenho é do pt
é fã que sabia não se quer começar já
para a normal ea beleza começa o filme
um cara conversando com duas menininhas
e minha filha o seu dom ea força você
vai ter que aprender a lidar com isso
aponta para outro seu dom é o pensamento
a sua força sua mentalidade
você vai ter que aprender a lidar com
isso e pronto com as palavras daí a
almofada o milagrão power rangers e na
família na casa nova para começa a mexer
numa caixa acho uma câmera antiga o que
ele tem que me enchem porque ele não
deixa as coisas lá que achou na casa
dela macho começa a usar as coisas que
encontraram na casa velha vai da média
global como mudar de casa vou marcar o
primeiro gol vou fazer tocar fogo de
tudo o que tiver a rodeia de carvão
bottas cama vão botar cama box por
satanás não caber em baixo achei uma
boneca nessa casa antiga toca fogo que
eu já assisti annabelle o cara pega essa
câmera que ele achou na casa tive começa
a filmar as coisas começam a fazer tipo
um deles blog só que poderia ficar uma
câmera pega umas coisas do além que não
devolve o satanás não dá né aí vai
começar com a filha dele que é
pequenininho e ela diz que tá brincando
com um amigo invisível vai dar merda
pois ele vai filmar casa do nada passa
um vulto
meu deus amou o que é isso companheiro
que eu lembrei que
engraçado quando passa e se volta à
cadeira mexes oncinha câmera da casa
antiga criança falando com um amigo
invisível cadeiras e mestre zinho macho
vai embora dessa casa por favor a mulher
pega a câmera para experimentar passa um
vulto tomei um susto macho troco com
tanta força que eu acho que a bolsa vem
para na garganta no gol eu acho
engraçado é que em filme de terror a
criança conversa com o diário a câmera
se mexe só a câmera filma acordo a lei
eo povo achar normal meu deus acho que
vi algo estranho ontem à noite olha que
minha câmera filmou o vejam isso lá
atrás da televisão a cara do satanás
desenhada para ficar até maquiar o meu
deus eu vejo algo estranho que será isso
o chefe o meu deus estou começando a
achar que tem algo estranho com essa
casa graça acabou de filmar o sábado na
ilha ainda acha que tem algo estranho
isso em filme que na vida real se for na
cozinha fabril na madeira já é demorar 2
segundo abílio de medeiros essa
geladeira está com o demônio chão o
pastor meu deus eu escolho deus eu tiro
de moura da geladeira e o cara vai
perguntar pra filha com quem ela está
conversando ea menina não quer dizer não
e conta filha com quem você estava
conversando com você tem um amigo
invisível com a minha responde só assim
eu não quero falar sobre isso em filme
se fosse lá em casa é assim que esse
amigo teu em adotar medidas a tomar isto
vai aprender até amigo everton e eu
quero - sabe que o paredão com esse tal
de fato mas ele viu eu tenho pra mim que
esse fato mas tão amiguinhos droga aí o
cara de noite spb leite para beber leite
a casa assombrada a minha conversa com
kaká um cara frio loucão ele desce o
bebê leite e deixa a luz apagada efe
ponto de filme é buscar buscar no
assassinato da casa ligado muito meu
amigo e para o bebê leite bebe água
benta o cara bota câmera no quarto da
menina para filmar quando penso que não
meu deus do céu amor que diabos é isso
eu falei da melo de amor treino
a câmera filma um negócio preto assim o
voando assim os ainda assim concorda
menina isso aí já era o motivo que o
separa da mulher casar com o impacto não
tinha de noite a mãe para o acostamento
da pista na copinha
a mãe ligou para eu pagar até eu se
fosse o padre já não ia porque padre em
filme de terror só tomo não fosse paga a
situação deve ficar ligado pra mim e
falam pra frente não trabalha com a
escolha a gente trabalha com água da
hóstia aiea no recall de demônio é outro
departamento transferir o senhor que viu
mexer com já pra lá de noite começa a
mesma coisa a mim agora do nada eu tenho
de pensar na coisa toda hora alguém que
rompe novo essa menina pra mim satanás
aparece atrás do carro
o moleque corre pela companhia se
desconectar do fogão macho quando eles
olha o satanás em sainde tarde o fogão
gigante assim parecendo russo vereadores
por favor me buscar o que está
descontrolado aqui em casa só que na
opinião a eleição sata lá - tem como
base a galera liga da justiça para
conter também chama todo mundo é coli
deus deus é massa cinemas mais surge
desse time faz curto e fique dia graças
a deus de dia meu deus do céu graças a
deus não parte de dia nesse filme de
terror de duas horas e dez minutos de
jogo record noite eu sei que já sabe é
que só tem noites que é gravado em dois
do brasil quando o filho do diabo japão
gravá lá de noite eo povo conversando de
casa tomando leite com mais na moda
acabou satanás estava na casa da pessoa
de noite e de dia todo mundo normal após
cena de som e todo mundo em casa eu
parei o icms por um trabalho não está
tudo em casa sabe o que é o bolsa
família como o da dilma e o primeiro foi
para casa e fica impressionada que
acontece qualquer coisa qualquer coisa
pois o filme de terror já fico do medo
que não cabe nem paga
a tomada saiu que é tomada se você vai
gostar desse vídeo já sabe é só clicar
em gostei aqui no youtube e me ajuda
demais e volta lá no facebook ou porque
se um vídeo novo galera não sei que ela
se calasse clique em curtir lá e marca
um amigo seu que assistiu à atividade
paranormal vai assistir lá nos
comentários que bush filme de terror que
não curte uma vez e acho engraçado esse
vídeo e comente aqui embaixo é o filme
que você quer que eu comente aqui é isso
aí pai é na equipe